so the wawa company slogan is always a
new encounter what does this entail and
where do you find new content for a
while maybe I consider myself other one
of the big fan of wawa as a viewers so
whenever I find a great content as a
viewer if I enjoyed it I really want to
share this feeling with the viewers for
example when you see it a great movie
maybe the next day you want to tell
their friends and then share the feeling
and it's the same thing the that's their
my way to find a content and from my
curiosity and maybe I have a wide range
of curiosity compared to the ordinary
people and and then sometimes I feel
like I have to watch this because of my
job and then I enjoyed it and I entered
I want to introduce to the viewers so
that's the way I'm i try to open my
window as much as I can
you